bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver sur LCP dans Ça vous
regarde ce soir connaître l'histoire de
l'extrême droite pour mieux la combattre
bonsoir Renaudie bonsoir merci d'être
notre grand témoin ce soir journaliste à
France Info et à haré aux manettes de de
28 minutes le weekend vous publiez
aujourd'hui l'assiégé chez laates une
enquête fouillée sur une figure discrè
mais centrale de l'extrême droite
française Dominique vennerre connu pour
son suicide spectaculaire au pied de
Notre-Dame il y a quelques années obsédé
par le grand remplacement la race
blanche vous nous direz pourquoi il
influence encore aujourd'hui largement
le parti de Marine Le Pen et celui
d'ériic Zemour notre grand débat ce soir
fête des enfants le chef de l'État a
surpris en proposant de relancer la
natalité en recul net dans le pays congé
de
plan de lutte contre l'infertilité de
quoi inverser la tendance moins de
700000 naissances en 2023 nous en
débattons dans un instant sur ce plateau
avec mes invités enfin ns franchi ce
soir le parti prix politique y Go
l'international vincentug et puis
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée avec els mondingava voilà
pour le menu on y va Ren ça vous regarde
c'est
parti
[Musique]
nom de code le réarmement démographique
traduction la relance de la natalité
Emmanuel Macron Renou donc avec une
vieille ancienne un pays qui va bien est
un pays qui fait des enfants mais a-t-il
forcément raison pourquoi la famille
nombreuse disparaît et va-t-on vers une
société de l'enfant unique enfin que
pensez des propositions présidentielles
bonsoir ellodie Jacquie Laforge bonsoir
merci d'être là vous êtes député MoDem
de l'iser et vice-présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale vous débattez ce
soir avec Julien Aubert bonsoir ravi de
vous retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes
vice-président des républicains ancien
député LR de vaulus bonsoir Gilles Pison
bienvenue vous êtes chercheur à l'INED
l'Institut national des études
démographiques votre atlas de la
population mondiale mondial vient de
paraître chez autrement enfin bonsoir
Léa chambonscel bonsoir visage am Milé
de cette émission merci d'être là
militante féministe et fondatrice du
média en ligne popol vous aussi vous
publiez un livre au revoir Simon
manifeste pour un féminisme politique et
révolutionnaire c'est chez bfond Renaud
di n'hésitez pas à intervenir je vous ai
entendu dans les informé de France info
sur ce même sujet donc allez-y
interpeller analyser on commence par
planter le décor les chiffres de la
baisse de la natalité les solutions
présidentielles c'est dans le recap de
Valérie
Brochard et bonsoir chère Valérie
bonsoir bonsoir à tous Alors ça va pas
la natalité dans le pays c'est un peu
panique à bord exactement Myriam les
chiffres de l'INC sont tombés depuis
2010 les françaises font de moins en
moins d'enfants et la Chute s'accélère
depuis l'année dernière on note une
baisse de 6,6 % en 2023 année qui a vu
nître moins de 700000 bébés sur notre
territoire 48000 nouveau nés de moins
qu'en 2022 et bien c'est l'équivalent de
d'une ville comme sa Malo voilà qui rend
la chose un petit peu plus concrète le
taux de fécondité a donc dégringolé à
1,68 enfants par femme des données qui
inquiète très très sérieusement Sylvain
Bayard une société qui ne fait pas
d'enfant est une société qui va mourir
et donc il est important pour nous pour
ce que nous sommes pour ce qui'est la
France d'avoir des enfants on fait des
enfants parce que c'est le sens de
l'histoire de construire une
civilisation qui est la nôtre qui est
française et de faire en sorte qu'elle
continue elle perdure alors pour que
perdure notre civilisation française
bien j'ai une question dis président
comment on fait les bébés et bien
Emmanuel Macron ne s'est pas caché
derrière une bouteille de lait lors de
sa conférence de presse il a même lancé
plusieurs pistes pour répondre à cette
crise de la natalité on l'écoute notre
France sera aussi plus forte par la
relance de sa natalité je voudrais
insister sur deux points pour essayer
d'améliorer les choses je crois
profondément que la mise en place d'un
nouveau congé de naissance sera un
élément utile dans une une telle
stratégie la natalité baisse aussi parce
que l'infertilité
progresse un grand plan de lutte contre
ce fléo sera engagé pour permettre
justement ce réarmement démographique
donc première munition reprendre le
rapport pour une grande stratégie
nationale de lutte contre l'infertilité
qui avait été remis sur le bureau
d'Olivier verrant quand il était alors
ministre de la Santé seconde cartouche
vous l'avez entendu réformé le congé
parental de 429 € par mois aujourd'hui
versé par la Sécurité sociale qui sera
donc transformé en congé de naissance et
ainsi donner droit aux parents à une
allocation qui serait versée cette fois
par la CAF d'une valeur proportionnée au
salaire mais sur une période plus courte
voilà pour les solutions plutôt des
injonctions qui ne plaisent pas à tout
le monde à commencer par les
associations féministes de dire à toutes
les auditrices qui ont fait le choix de
ne pas avoir d'enfants qu'elles ont le
droit que ça n'est pas un problème
qu'elles ne sont en train de trahir ni
la patrie ni leur famille et que et
qu'il faut aussi faire attention avec
tous ces discours qui laisserait à
penser qu'il y aurait une bonne manière
d'être une femme et ce serait d'être une
mère on peut être une femme sans être
mère il y a aucun problème avec ça
est-ce que est-ce que nos abdomens sont
des armes myiam est-ce que le futur des
femmes en France c'est de nous réduire à
une mission de procréation mais mais la
vraie question la seule qui compte myiam
c'est pas d'en faire des enfants c'est
surtout
ça
[Musique]
taisez-vous
taisez-vous et oui et oui Myriam qui va
s'en occuper après et combien ça coûte
moins de bébés c'est aussi moins
d'allocation avers c'est moins de moins
de dépenses pardon pour les crèches ou
le sy le système scolaire mais après
c'est aussi moins de travailleurs pour
créer de la richesse bref je vous laisse
réfléchir à à tout ça sur le plateau
pendant ce temps-là moi je vais passer
un petit coup de fil à Emmanuel et
Brigitte Macron pour savoir si
éventuellement il serait disponible pour
un petit babys sitting samedi
soir merci merci beaucoup Valérie on va
on va parler des propositions du chef de
l'État dans dans un instant dans une
deuxième partie mais on va commencer
pour par les chiffres et puis des des
débuts d'explication Gil Pison le
Parisien je suis sûr que vous avez vu ce
titre il y a de jours titré sur la
tentation de l'enfant unique un bébé et
c'est tout est-ce qu'on en est là le
Baby crash français
les Français ne veulent plus faire
d'enfant c'est un peu aller vite en
besogne que de dire ça c'est pas du tout
le cas on le sait et en plus si on prend
du recul votre courbe qui s'est affiché
tout à l'heure partait de 2010 et
montrait une baisse des naissances
depuis 2010 mais si on avait pris un
recul historique plus important depuis
la fin du baby boom il y a 50 ans le
nombre de naissance fluctue d'une année
à l'autre avec des péries
où elles ont tendance à baisser comme
depuis 2010 et aussi comme dans les
années 80 et le début des années 90 et
puis des période où elles ont tendance à
augmenter et sur la période
depuis pour lesquels on peut faire un
bilan alors les femmes qui ont fêté leur
50e anniversaire l'an passé en 2023 donc
qui sont nés en 1973 elles ont eu deux
enfants en moyenne chacune celles qui
ont fêté leur 40e anniversaire
es ils en ont eu 1,99 et donc d'ici 50
ans ils en auront eu un peu plus que de
c'est intéressant vous parlez du taux de
fécondité je vous interromps parce que
quand même
1,7 a une stabilité de la fécondité la
question c'est est-ce que les femmes qui
sont en train d'avoir des enfants qui
sont dans la trentaine puisque c'est
l'âge moyen à la maternité 31 ans elles
en ont eu déjà 0,9 celles qui sont nées
en 1993 est-ce que d'ici la cinquantaine
elles vont en
avoir pour arriver à deux enfants à 50
ans c'est la question c'est pas exclu et
donc au-delà de ces fluctuations d'une
période à l'autre en France il y a une
relative stabilité de la fécondité
depuis la fin du déb qu' qualifie quand
même d'historique hein parce que c'est
la première fois qu'on on passe en
dessous de la barre des 700000 il
A3 94 on a atteint un point bas en
termeicateur de fécondé
est que conjctur c'est une question
justement et on a besoin de recherche
supplémentairire il faut savoir que ce
mouvement de baisse on l'observe dans
tous les pays européens pratiquement au
cours de ces dernières années et même si
la fécondité baisse ces dernières années
en France ce pays reste le plus fécond
d'Europe donc quand on on part on se
cons oui on peut se poser la question
qu'est-ce qui se passe mais c'est vrai
il faut se la poser pour tous les pays
d'Europe et même au-delà en Asie de
l'est Japon Taïwan la Corée du Sud où le
niveau de fécondité en Corée du Sud a
atteint 0,7 enfants par femme vous voyez
bien que la France n'en est pas
là on va pas vers un modèle en tout cas
pour l'instant avec uniquement un enfant
voire pas du tout Elodie Jacquier
Laforge on peut se consoler en regardant
nos voisins européens l'Allemagne par
exemple mais quand même on voit bien que
même si les enfants les Français veulent
toujours faire des enfants ils en font
moins ça veut dire la famille deux
enfants pas plus le modèle de trois
enfants on voit qu'il est de moins en
moins fréquent ça ça vous inquiète ou
pas alors moi ben c'est c'est pas
forcément une inquiétude comme ça je je
tous les jours je me dis pas je suis
très inquiète de la baisse de la
natalité mais on voit effectivement
qu'il y a à la fois chaque année une
baisse et qu'en tout cas il y a une
préoccupation aujourd'hui euh des
Français sur ce sujet une préoccupation
politique qui qui existe mais des
enfants mais pas trop finalement ça
correspond à à l'époque vous l'expliquez
comment il y a il y a de l'anxiété la
vie cher en tout cas je pense qu'il y a
pas une seule raison euh qui peut y
avoir comme on disait à l'instant des
raisons conjoncturelles il peut y avoir
des raisons structurelles en tout cas
moi ce qui me paraît extrêmement
important c'est tout ce qui concerne
l'égalité et finalement le projet euh de
de parents euh il doit se construire
avec les parents avec les deux parents
il faut pouvoir accompagner les femmes
qui ont ce désir de de
maternité et lever les freins lever les
freins mais c'est des freins qui sont
rel justement à l'égalité et donc c'est
euh si on part sur les propositions qui
sont faites pouvoir permettre d'avoir un
un accueil pour son enfant de pouvoir
partir au travail qu'on soit la mère ou
le père per le cœur en tout cas pas
forcément trop lourd de quitter son
enfant et de savoir qu'il est bien et
que les choses vont bien se passer pour
lui et tout ça à mon sens est lié à
l'égalité puisque aujourd'hui la
Fondation des femmes parle du coût
d'être mère du coup en terme il existe
ce cou il existe ce c'est indéniable à
la fois en terme de progression de
carrière on va poser la question à une
jeune femme vous avez un projet d'enfant
est-ce qu'on va le poser à un homme non
un homme qui devient père pas tous mais
la plupart gardent le même temps de lois
une injonction sociale encore très forte
pr on voit bien les question de
l'égalité pour moi en tout cas sont
majeurs aujourd'hui si on veut permettre
à chaque parent de pouvoir mener à terme
les choses chent un peu quand même les
haambons sel dans quel sens d'après vous
avoir un enfant c'est devenu un choix
parmi d'autres ou on en est pas là oui
je pense que ça ça reste un choix
parfois comment dire effectivement
contraint par la réalité de la
répartition des charges au sein d'un
foyer et je pense que vous avez tout à
fait raison lorsque vous dites qu'il
faut impérativement sortir aussi d'une
d'une de la charge mentale on a beaucoup
parlé de la charge mentale un certain
temps en disant que effectivement elle
repose quand même essentiellement sur
les mères plus que sur les pères la
répartition aussi de tout ce qu'on
appelle le travail reproductif qui est
de faire attention aux autres de
s'occuper des enfants et cetera on voit
que ça repose encore beaucoup beaucoup
hélas sur les femmes et que ça il faut
un rééquilibrage nécessaire et parmi les
causes vous vous voyez cette difficile
conciliation avec avec la carrière il y
a des pays par exemple comme en
Allemagne où les féministes ont un
discours en disant c'est impossible de
faire les deux c'est l'un ou l'autre la
carrière ou la famille alors après c'est
très difficile effectivement d'être dans
la tête des gens vous vous disiez qu'on
manque encore donné on en est enfin on
manque on manque encore aujourd'hui de
données pour expliquer potentiellement
ce recul qui vraisemblablement selon
monsieur n'est pas tout à fait avéré il
y a
effectivement plein de raisons je veux
dire on est dans une situation
économique qui est difficile vous
parliez d'inflation tout à l'heure il y
aussi les incertitudes quant au
changement au dérèglement climatiques il
a aussi une situation de de de comment
dire de l'enfance aujourd'hui qui est
difficile aujourd'hui en France je veux
dire on parle d'un pays où il y a encore
il y a près de 2000 enfants qui dorment
dans la rue il y a aussi des choses
qu'il faut mettre en enfin comprendre
des des craintes de de de ce que c'est
que d'avoir aujourd'hui la
responsabilité aussi d'avoir des enfants
dans une société qui est
encore les choses sont très difficiles
il y a des des difficultés sociales qui
sont réelles des
incertitudes un peu natalist du
président et le c'est vrai que pour moi
elle me elle elle me surprend dans le
sens où on voit bien que c'est c'est une
injonction déjà on parle de réarmement
le terme n'est pas àodin on est quand on
on regarde et qu'on prend un peu de
recul par rapport à toute cette
conférence de presse on voit que la
question du moment est revenue
régulièrement donc il y a quand même une
volonté presque de décloisonner le civil
du militaire qui est un peu surprenante
les termes sont choisis nous savons
queemmanuel Macron est quelqu'un
d'intelligent ça on peut pas lui enlever
les termes sont choisis c'est quoi il
parle et il sait comment il parle le
réarmement démographiqueement
démographique c'est un terme qui un peu
c'est une expression qui est assez
surprenante et qui en plus donne
l'impression qu'on a une envie de
contrôler le corps des autres et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est un peu
inquiétante à mon sens parce que quand
on voit aussi quand on on regarde de
manière plus large la question par
exemple du du retour de l'uniforme à
l'école c'est aussi une façon plus ou
moins de contrôler les corps et ça c'est
quelque chose qui pour
Mo non ça rel des régimes de natalité ni
vêt
s droite vous inquiète déj on l'IM les
républain rembltion son vraiment
inquiets vraiment préoccupés par ces
chiffres parce que parce que les enfants
c'est l'avenir du pays parce que ce sont
les travailleurs de demain parce que ce
sont les citoyens de demain parce que
nous avons aussi bon je veux pas parler
d'immigration mais il y a le tau de
fécondité et distinct entre le je dirais
les les Français de première génération
et les autres ce qui peut conduire
ensuite à des problèmes d'assimilation
républicaines à des problèmes de je
dirais de d'assimilation par le
chefétat d'ailleurs l'a dit lors de sa
conférence de presse moins d'enfance et
moins de moins d'œuvres c'est déjà le
cas dans dans certains secteurs en
tension il y a de la pén et donc il
faudra sauf qu'on a des débats ensuite
très tendus sur la question migratoire
et moi je crois si vous voulez que
aujourd'hui nous avons le choix
finalement de de maîtriser la fécondité
les femmes mais aussi les hommes et et
que par conséquent il y a un choix
qualitatif qui se fait c'estàdire que
nous investissons dans les enfants de
manière différente que nos prédécesseurs
euh moi je me rappelle ma ma grand-mère
elle avait perdu ils étaaiit 7 ou h elle
avait perdu je crois deux de deux frères
ou sœurs très jeunes et c'était quelque
chose de d'assez fréquent dans les
sociétés rurales du début du siècle on
ne s'attachait pas autant aux enfants
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup plus de
projection et donc on veut des enfants
mais on veut pouvoir leur apporter
d'abord une qualité de vie et aussi que
pour les parents une responsabilité de
s'en occuper de bien s'en occuper est-ce
que c'est pas mieux ça finalement oui
c'est très bien mais du coup et bien des
problèmes comme le manque de crèche le
manque de bras pour faire garder
l'injonction aussi de d'avoir une
carrière et le fait de devoir arbitrer
en conséquence avec derrière la
culpabilité d'être un mauvais père ou
une mauvaise mère toutes ces questions
rétroagissent et et donc bah je pense
que vous avez une forme de calcul d'e de
ceux qui en tout cas ont les moyens de
de de faire ces arbitrages de dire ben
je vais va peut-être avoir un ou deux et
je vais pouvoir leur donner tout ce que
je peux leur donner plutôt que d'en
avoir trois ou quatre et de de pas être
en mesure de gérer ou de mesure de leur
amener le l'univers qualitatif qu'ils
veulent et la question de l'anxiété par
rapport au monde fait partie aussi de
cette question de la qualité par rapport
à la quantité de dire bah je ce monde de
demain m'apparaît anxiogène est-ce que
vraiment j'ai envie d'avoir des enfants
je parle notamment des plus jeunes qui
vont grandir dans ce monde que je juge
peut-être dangereux sauvage anxiogè avec
les sujets de climat et cetera je crois
que ça j aussi c'est intéressant c'est
un sujet qui est évidemment émidemment
intime qui est aussi social sociétal et
très très politique il y a une obsession
nataliste en France est-ce que ça vous a
choqué que le Président de la République
c'est pas le premier hein veul relancer
la natalité non pas du tout non non je
pense que c'est fait partie évidemment
des politiques publiques c'est
évidemment une
responsabilité des gouvernants quel que
soit leur couleur politique et quelle
que soit la période de l'histoire dans
laquelle on est que de se soucier du
nouvellement des générations d'un pays
c'est évident ensuite on peut discuter
des termes ou des pistes évidemment r
armement démographique c'est une
formule mal à droite il y a je pense qu'
il faut éviter plusieurs écueils dans ce
débat il faut éviter évidemment
l'jonction morale il faut les les femmes
sont évidemment libres de faire ce qu'
ce qu'elles veulent et il faut
absolument pas faire peser une
quelconque forme de culpabilité sur
celles qui ont choisi de ne pas avoir
d'enfant ou ou d'avoir un seul enfant il
faut éviter aussi de verser dans un une
vision apocalyptique qui consisterait à
prophétiser la disparition du pays à
court terme reste que il y a une réalité
il faut pas se voer la face non plus
nous sommes un pays et un continent
d'ailleurs effectivement c'est un
problème qui se pose à l'ensemble du
continent européen qui vieillit le
vieillissement de la population le fait
qu'il y ait moins de naissance moins de
renouvellement de générations et
davantage de de de de vieux une une une
un vieillissement démographique
forcément un problème c'est pas
forcément un bon signe c'est pas le
signe forcément d'un pays ou d'un
continent qui se porte bien et c'est
vrai que je pense que ça participe de
l'espèce de sentiment un peu de de
déclassement de je sais pas quel est le
bon terme ou de névrose ou d'angoisse
quasiment à l'échelle européenne on a
sentiment d'ê un vieux on a le sentiment
d'être un vieux continent immobile en
déclin entre guillemets au regard d'un
certain nombre d'autres régions du monde
et juste un tout dernier point je pense
pas qu'une politique dite nataliste à
savoir les instruments qu'on utilise que
ce soit une obsession de droite ou de
gauche ça peut être classé à droite
quand on effectivement on tient un
discours apocalyptique sur l'éventuelle
disparition d'une civilisation mais par
exemple c'est de gauche que de défendre
le renouvellement des générations pour
assurer la survie du système de retraite
par répartition moins il y aura de jeune
plus le système de retraite par
répartition sera en danger évidemment
donc
ça la droite pas toujours mené la même
politique que la gauche alors justement
on va se pencher sur les propositions
présidentielles pour relancer la
natalité le chef de l'État propose un
nouveau congé congé de naissance en lieu
et place du congé parental actuel plus
court mais mieux rémunéré explication
Hélène Bonduel réaction juste
après
tu as été sage s bien passé en 10ant le
nombre de congés parentaux a diminué de
moitié 246000 parents seulement a ont eu
recours en 2020 moins d'un % des paires
voilà pourquoi le président de la
République a décidé de le remplacer par
un congé de naissance il sera plus court
que le congé parental actuel qui peut
parfois aller jusqu'à 3 ans et qui
éloigne beaucoup de femmes du marché du
travail mais qui aussi crée beaucoup
d'angoisse parce qu'il est extrêmement
peu et mal rémunéré actuellement
rémunéré par un forfait de 429 € mensuel
le congé parental est peu attractif le
nouveau congé de naissance serait plus
court 6 mois et il engloberait le congé
de maternité pour les femmes et de
paternité pour les hommes chaque parent
pourrait choisir de le prendre en même
temps ou
successivement pour l'Union nationale
des familles c'est une bonne nouvelle le
fait en tout cas qu'on qu'on permette si
possible de rendre ce congé plus
attractif durant la première année ça
nous paraît vraiment une bonne chose
mais reste à voir quel sera le niveau
d'indéisation il faut qu'il soit
vraiment conséquent pour que vraiment ce
congé soit pris une véritable révolution
je dirais même dans la façon dont les
parents peuvent conseiller leur vie
familiale et et leur vie professionnelle
alors comment sera-t-il rémunéré au
forfait ou en proportion des revenus
comme dans certains pays nordiques la
ministre de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes évoque un pourcentage du
revenu actuel sans préciser combien
c'est ça qu'on est en train de de
déterminer évidemment bien au-delà des
429 € l'objectif c'est que ce soit
proportionné au salaire alors évidemment
ce sera pas maintient à 100 % de votre
salaire pour des raisons évidentes donc
on est en train de le déterminer on ira
bien au-delà des 429 € maximum maximum
qui était accordé aux parents chaque
mois parce que sinon enc une fois ça
veut dire que les classes moyennes elles
peuvent pas reste aussi à améliorer le
mode de garde au retour du congé de
naissance les modalités doivent
maintenant faire l'objet de discussion
avec les partenaires sociaux Gill bison
le démographe que vous êtes je suis sûre
que vous avez étudié les liens entre les
incitations financières et la natalité
ils existent ces liens là on peut
inciter en disant tiens vous irez en
congé si vous le souhaitez plus
longtemps et en plus enfin plus
longtemps moins longtemps
qu'actuellement mais mieux rémunéré
pourquoi pas même presque aligné sur le
salaire est-ce que ça ça
marche alors ce que nous apprennent les
comparaisons internationale notamment en
Europe parce que tous les pays européens
ont une politique familiale tous ils
offrent des allocations pour les enfants
des congés parentaux des offres de garde
d'enfants aussi mais les pays du nord de
l'Europe et il faut mettre la France
avec ce groupe là on ben globalement
une politique familiale qui représente
une investissement en terme budgétaire
en part du PIB qui est nettement plus
importante que celle des pays du Sud et
notamment les congés parentaux qui
existent dans tous les pays notamment
dans les pays du Sud où les femmes ont
le moins d'enfants c'est les italienses
et les Espagnols qui sont les moins
fécondes actuellement avec 1,2 enfants
par femme et la France avec 1,7 qui est
en en tête il y a des congés parentaux
en Italie en Espagne mais ils sont très
faiblement rémunérés ils sont long et
donc cette mesure rapprocherait la
France de ce qui se pratique dans les
pays du nord de l'Europe qui sont plus
féconds et aussi de l'Allemagne mais les
congés parentaux bien rémunéré ça fait
c'est une des mesures de la familiale
parce que il y a l'offre de garde
d'enfants qui est aussi très faible dans
les pays du sud de l'Europe et les
femmes les couples sont obligés de
garder eux-mêmes les enfants ou de
recourir à la famille alors que dans les
pays du nord de l'Europe et en France il
y a une offre de garde beaucoup plus
importante même si elle est insuffisante
on voit bien même France quand même he
56 % j'ai vu ce chiffre aujourd'hui des
parents euh gardent leur nourrisson chez
eux faute de mode de garde donc ça ne
peut pas suffir euh vous vous allez
voter tout ça j'imagine ça ça va passer
par la loi à l'Assemblée ce nouveau
congé de naissance c'est une une partie
de la solution c'est ça en tout cas
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet qui a
d'ors et déjà été testé c'est vrai que
ce congé parental de 3 ans sous des
précédents
aussiem majorité on on voit et puis ça
avait été élargi aux hommes et on on
voyait alors les hommes encore moins oui
mais on voit fin finalement que le le
fait pour moi en tout cas d'avoir une
durée plus courte mieux indemnisé ça
répond je crois à la situation actuelle
qui est que 1 % des hommes ne ne
prennent pas ce congé parental parce que
encore aujourd'hui les salaires des
hommes sont plus élevés que ceux des
femmes c'est pour ça j'en reviens à
l'égalité donc si c'est proportionné la
rémunération en gros les hommes qui
gagnent bien pénalis pourrait être
incité à prendre leur congé bah en tout
cas ça pénalise moins le ménage puisque
on on voit bien que c'est c'est c'est
tout ça est quand même assez concret
finalement et ça va coûter assez cher à
l'État ça vous avez le ça ça va
être ça va être budgeté c'est quand même
de façon beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
courte moi ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est aussi que ça puisse se faire euh
alors je dans l'idéal je pense qu'il
faut laisser vraiment les familles
s'organiser et pas forcément faire 6
mois 6 mois il faut peut-être aussi
donner une certaine souplesse puisque ça
peut permettre aussi et au père et à la
mère de pouvoir aussi adapter les choses
et puis je crois aussi qu'il faut qu'on
intègre de façon collective aussi que un
père qui prend un congé parental et bien
c'est très bien bien c'est normal de
prendre ses congés paternités c'est
totalement normal aussi et donc c'est à
la société dans son ensemble et aussi
aux employeurs de d'assimiler le fait
que le père aussi a un enfant enfin ça
paraît bizarre de le dire comme ça mais
c'est une réalit c'est vrai que la
question qui va garder le nourrisson
avec le retour au travail c'est la
grande question des des parents Julien
Aubert vous n'êtes plus député mais vous
auriez pu voter une telle mesure la
droite elle veut carrément revenir sur
le C familiale c'est ça moi si vous
voulez je je suis assez sceptique parce
que d'abord je je pense que dans le cœur
du de la politique familiale c'est c'est
moins le congé à la naissance qui est
important même si c'est un élément
important que ce qui a été démantelé
sous François Hollande c'est-à-dire
l'universalité des allocations
familiales et de manière générale les
aides de longue durée qui qui permettent
effectivement de neutraliser on parle
souvent d'égalité pour moi le sujet
c'est que que vous soyez il y a un
couple qui décidait d'avoir un enfant ou
un couple qui ne qui décide de ne pas en
avoir il ne faut pas que le choix
d'avoir un enfant vienne impacctter
votre mode de vie vous V affaires on ny
est pas mais dans cette hypothèse vous
reviendriez sur la mise sous conditions
de ressources des allocations familiale
c'est François Hollande he qui l'avait
installé et d'ailleurs il y a une petite
phrase qui y a pas il av pas de droit de
suite dans cette conférence de presse
donc personne n'a pu s essayer de
préciser la pensée du président mais à
cette question ROR berger avait dit euh
que on pouvait envisager de de revenir
sur cette mise sous conditions de
ressources il a dit il y a derrière cela
peut-être des choix prijadice sur
certains sujets financiers un choix
auquel il aurait d'ailleurs participé
puisqu'il était à
l'époque vous pourriez revenir sur en
tout cas le le groupe démocrate de la
précédente mandature avait fait des
propositions en ce sens donc not groupe
de revenir de revenir à
l'universalisation quand on parle du
congé de
naissancees favor mais le débat sur le
débat entre je dis dirait le forfait ou
le le pourcentage de salaire c'est en
réalité il faut parler des principes
c'est le fait de savoir si effectivement
on est pour l'universalité et dans ce
cas-là si on est pour l'universalité on
prend un pourcentage du revenu pour
neutraliser il faut il faut se demander
quel est l'objectif pour moi la première
égalité c'est l'égalité entre ceux qui
décident d'avoir des enfants et ceux qui
décident de ne pas en avoir si quand
vous décidez de vous investir pour
l'avenir de la nation et aussi pour un
projet de vie vous êtes systématiquement
pascment M in les é avez des conditions
de salaire
avez moins
deersalité c'est ça c'est de considérer
parce que sinon vous avez aussi un bien
c'est vous pouvez avoir des gens qui ont
des moyens d'avoir des enfants et qui
n'en ont pas c'est pas forcément
d'ailleurs une bonne idée parce qu'ils
ont des choses à transmettre il y a et
la capacité justement aussi de pour voir
financièrement à leur à leur
développement et de les accompagner donc
je pense que si vous voulez il faut pas
que un moment donné la politique
familiale a un biais dans les dans les
les chamb B il pourrait aller jusque là
euh Emmanuel Macron qui venant du centre
gauche relançant son son quinquena on
sent que la droite vaut trait le modemme
vaut trait bon les macronist c'est c'est
moins sûr hein historique c'est
difficile c'est difficile à déterminer
mais je pense qu' il est aussi important
de de de replacer un peu les choses dans
leur contexte et de dire de quoi on
parle réellement puisque ce qu'on
constate en fait c'est que il y a une
association entre croissance
démographique et dans la tête du chef de
l'État et croissance économique et cette
association en fait n'est pas toujours
vérifiée on prend par par exemple le cas
de l'Allemagne qui est un un pays où il
y a finalement une croissance
démographique qui est bien plus faible
qu'en France mais une croissance
économique qui est évidemment bien plus
importante il y a aussi un autre élément
qui est celui des des incitations
justement on parlait des incitations
financières est-ce qu'elles ont
effectivement un impact sur la natalité
et le taux de natalité il y a un de vos
collègues que vous devez certainement
connaître Hervé lebra qui répondait
aujourd'hui dans mdiaparten qui disait
qu'en fait non ça n'a jamais été
véritablement vérifié en fait donc il y
a aussi peut-être la question qu' faut
qu'on se pose c'est qu'est-ce qu'on veut
réellement pourquoi pourquoi relancer ce
débat actuellement et puis aussi quand
même intéressant parce que c'est vrai
que il y a ce sentiment d'injonction qui
est fait aux femmes je pense que c'est
important quand même qu'il faut qu'on on
y revienne alors même qu'aujourd'hui
l'Assemblée nationale statué sur l'IVG
dans la Constitution en commission donc
c'est vrai que le timing est un peu
étonnant aussi il y a aussi
d'aut croissance démographique égale
croissance économique bien sûr bon à
discuter mais pour compléter ce qui
vient d'être dit quand on compare les
pays quand on compare leur niveau de
fécondité et puis leur politique
familiale on s'aperçoit que les pays où
les femmes et les couples ont le plus
d'enfants c'est ceux aujourd'hui où les
taux d'activité féminin sont les plus
élevés donc les femmes travaillent le
plus c'est les pays du nord de l'Europe
la France l'Allemagne sont en position
moyenne c'est aussi et surtout les pays
où les inégalités entre hommes et femmes
que ce soit au travail ou à la maison
sont les plus faibles et et ça a l'air
d'être un point clé c'est un meilleur
partage des tâches à la maison et une
égalité au travail et c'est les pays du
nord de l'Europe qui le réalisent même
si les inégalités persistent dans ces
pays-là oui c'est justement al
évidemment que la croissance
démographique participe de la croissance
économique ça c'est il y a pas de débat
là-dessus d'ailleurs quand il y a
insuffisamment de naissance on a recours
et on a besoin d'avoir recours à
l'immigration y compris pour assurer la
croissance économique mais pour cette
question de l'inégalité qui est
fondamental effectivement c'est ça le
problème de fond me semble-t-il et ça
explique évidemment et c'est bien leur
droit et c'est légitime que des femmes
ne veuillent pas avoir d'enfant parce
que ça va briser leur carrière
professionnelle ça va les freiner et
puis elles vont endurer en quelque sorte
elles vont supporter le poids justement
que ça représente aussi de de de de
d'élever un enfant regarde un père
absent et cetera pourquoi je suggère
cette pisteel cette piste du congé de
naissance raccourci de 6 mois et mieux
rémunéré me semble une piste plus
intéressante que le congé parental pris
par à peine 1 2 3 % des des hommes mais
pourquoi ce congé de naissance ne pas
laisser la mère libre de le prendre ou
pas et l'imposer au pèrees ça ça serait
une vraie révolution qui pendant 6 mois
et l'imposer au Père l'imposer au Père
ça changerait mois ch allez làdus on
termine parce que parce que on le voit
bien euh ensuite et ça c'est une réalité
sociétale encore aujourd'hui encore
aujourd'hui effectivement euh l'homme a
beaucoup moins conscience et assume
beaucoup moins au fil de sa de sa
carrière de sa carrière professionnelle
et de son parcours euh ce que représente
le fait de s'occuper pourit faire
l'objet d' oui et puis ce que je voulais
dire et compléter que c'est que par
rapport au fait un enfant deux enfants
trois enfants finalement plus il y a
d'enfants dans la fratterie et moins le
père participe ah oui c'est désol vous
me laprenez voilà donc donc c'est c'est
pour dire que finalement on compte voilà
sur sur les P et l'encouragement soci il
faut peut-être la contrainte du
législateur ben
voilà je parlais pas d'injonction morale
la contrainte je paris honnêtement allez
on termine un homme proposé qu'on impose
aux femmes d'arrêter de travailler
pendant 6 mois tout le monde je dirais
pousserait des cris d'or frais quand on
parle de l'égalité hommes-femme ça va
aussi dans l'égalité de respect qu'on
peut avoir il faut arrêter aussi
d'envoyer des injonctions aux hommes
comme s'ils étaient
responsablesjonction je des
inégalit il y a du boulot en matière
d'injonction pour arriver à la parité on
s'arrête là merci beauoup on n pas eu le
temps de de parler de de l'infertilité
mais peut-être que c'est encore un autre
sujet qui fera l'objet d'un autre débat
merci à vous merci d'avoir participé en
direct sur LCP à ce débat vous restez
avec moi Renaud déie dans une dizaine de
minutes les affranchis pour leur partie
prix ce soir yelg s'interroge Macron
est-il réarmé pour durer Vincent eug
revient sur la situation en Équateur
après l'assassinat du procureur à qui
les gangs font la loi et puis au
programme de bonbon Express Elsa ce soir
el monagava je vous parle du coup de
froid c'est pas la météo c'est entre
François beou et Emmanuel Macron merci
les amis à tout à l'heure mais d'abord
on va plonger dans la tête de Dominique
vennerre au cœur de ces obsessions
identitaires votre enquête Renaud déie
est passionnante elle se lit comme un
roman elle est extrêmement documentée
l'assiégé chez la tess c'est l'histoire
d'un gourou caché de l'extrême droite
terrorisé par l'effondrement de
l'Occident il est discret mais pas moins
influent jusqu'à aujourd'hui encore on
voit cela dans l'invitation de mait
fréont alamondingava interview juste
après
si on vous invite Renault dé c'est parce
que vous nous faites découvrir une
figure clé et pourtant méconnue de
l'extrême droite contemporaine Dominique
vennerre dans l'assiégé le titre de
votre livre de lui on connaît surtout
son suicide spectaculaire dans la
cathédrale NotreDame de Paris Dominique
ven a laissé derrière lui une dernière
lettre dans laquelle il dit donner la
mort pour réveiller les consciences
assoupies son suicide a été salué hier
soir par quelques figures du Front
national comme Marine Le Pen Renault déi
vous êtes journaliste fin observateur de
la vie politique depuis près de 30 ans
et très tôt spécialiste de l'extrême
droite 17 ouvrages à votre actif le
premier en
1999 déjà une enquête sur le front
national aujourd'hui vous exhumez donc
l'histoire de dominique Venner historien
partis de l'Algérie française et
précurseur de la théorie du Grand
remplacement celui des populations
blanches par Cell venue d'Afrique une
menace obsessionnelle pour vénère qui
avait le sentiment d'être assiégé d'où
le titre de votre livre vous nous
plongez dans la tête de ce gourou de
l'extrême droite et du FN en particulier
en quête fouillée qu'il faut lire à
l'ône de la montée des populismes un peu
partout dans le monde et à quelques mois
des élections européennes pour
lesquelles le parti de Marine Le Pen et
de Jordan bardellaa est donné grand
gagnant alors à l'heure où la théorie du
Grand remplacement est entrée dans le
débat public une question pour vous
Renaud d'ÉIE ce soir dominique Venner
a-t-il réussi à imposer ses obsessions
au-delà de l'extrême
droite réponse au-delà je sais pas mais
à l'extrême droit c'est vrai que lire et
observver enquêter le cours de deque
Venner permet de comprendre aujourd'hui
les clés les clés de fonctionnement de
l'extrême droite qui s'agisse en France
en l'occurrence du rassembl national ou
de reconquête comme d'ailleurs à
l'échelle européenne où la même
obsession identitaire contribue à faire
prospérer l'extr mais quand on entend
Emmanuel Macron reprendre un slogan de
leurentvoquier 2018 éic cotti éc Zemour
2022 pour que la France reste la France
qu'est-ce qui il agite comme imaginaire
une France menacée de quoi de disparaî
par que la France reste la France la
France du bon sens de la résistance et
des lumières Eric Zemour ne préconise
absolument pas la France des Lumières ce
que je veux dire c'est que d'ailleurs
dans le dans les dans les référence de
d'Emmanuel Macron l'autre jour en
conférence de presse qu' y avait aussi
bien effectivement des choses qui
ressemblaient à Zemour ou veier que des
que des allusions à je mais c'est parce
que ce fantasme du Grand remplacement
c'est à ce poids installé dans le débat
public en tout cas il a été popularisé
que vous avez décidé d'enquêter sur
dominique Venner dominique Venner c'est
un personnage extrêmement méconnu qui
dans l'ombre a contribué à invent en
quelque sorte l'extrême droite moderne
ça ça remonte aux années 50 et aux
années 60 plutôt aux années 60
d'ailleurs c'est-à-dire une extrême
droite à l'échelle européenne qui est
obsédée par la question migratoire et
qui effectivement prophétise la
disparition de ce qu'il appelait la race
blanche et forcé de constater d'une part
qu'il a irrigué tout un pan de l'extrême
droite parce qu'il a aussi repensé
l'organisation d'extrême droite il a eu
beaucoup d'élèves beaucoup de disciples
génération après génération il a aussi
fréquenté évidemment Jean-Marie Le Pen
et unons sur la notion de grand
remplacement vous nous apprenez on
l'attribue très souvent à l'écrivain
Rena Camu c'est faux c'est pas non plus
dominique Venner pour être très précis
c'est René Binet au début des années 50
et il l' lu il a lu lui René Binet
Dominique véner c'était un un
intellectuel passionné passionné des
écrits effectivement les plus sulsureux
et il a il a imprégné l'extrêm de cette
obsession migratoire de ce concept
complotiste qui consiste à dire
qu'effectivement ce serait voulu par les
élites que de remplacer pour reprendre
leur terme la population occidentale par
des populations venues d'Afrique il
était Obs
ouais'hu alors rambinon dominique Venner
est né en 1935 enfant sous l'Occupation
il est issu d'une famille de de Cabo
dans quel milieu granditil en fait il
grandit dans un milieu il a un père qui
est membre du PPF le Parti Populaire
Français Jack Dorot donc
collaborationniste une grand-mère qui
lui fait découvrir la tenue l'élégance
des soldats allemands mais il est enfant
pendant la guerre lui évidemment n en 3
35 mais ce sont des images qui vont
peupler en quelque sorte son son enfant
un imaginaire euh qui qui repose
évidemment sur ces souvenirs là et c'est
quelqu'un qui ensuite va s'engager très
tôt parce que c'est quelqu'un qui aime
la guerre euh qui va s'engager très tôt
en Algérie en Algérie pas seulement
voilà oui pas seulement pour défendre en
fait l'Empire colonal mais pour défendre
déjà à l'époque ce qu'il considère comme
l'Occident menacé selon lui par
justement l'Afrique l'Algérie c'est
central vous raconte qu'il passe à tabat
des militants du FLN c'est là qu'il
développe une passion pour l'action
violente euh et les armes il va loin il
est jamais inquiété à cette il a jamais
été inquiété il a jamais été poursuivi
mais comme à l'époque on le sait il y a
eu nombre d'exactions commis par l'armée
française qui n'ont pas donné lieu à des
poursuites et ensuite après l'Algérie
après son engagement dans l'armée
l'armée il est déçu par les officiers
par ses supérieurs qui considère en gros
comme trop mou trop légaliste et il va
basculer dans le terrorisme avec du côté
de l'os un certain nombre d'attentats et
notamment d'ailleurs un attentat fantasm
contre le général de Gaul et une prise
de l'Élysée qui n'aura pas lieu
évidemment mais tout ça va lui valoir
plusieurs séjours en prison justement
parce qu'il a basculé en même temps dans
à un moment dans le terrorisme toujours
pour poursuivre ce combat identitaire
qui lui était cher la prison donc point
de bascule il change complètement de
méthode et il renonce à l'action
violente pourquoi il change de méthode
et il change pas de projet il faut bien
le comprendre c'est-à-dire qu'il va
effectivement en prison et ensuite dans
divers écrits mais notamment un texte
qu'il a écrit en prison qui s'appelle
pour une critique positive repenser
l'extrême droite moderne en disant il
faut que l'extrême droite arrête de se
lamenter sur la perte de l'empire
colonial l'Indochine l'Algérie et cetera
ou qu'elle arrête d'être obsédée par la
réhabilitation de la collaboration et du
maréchal Pétin mais elle doit défendre
l'Europe de demain toujours l'Europe de
demain l'Europe des blancs l'Occident
contre les vagues migratoires et donc il
va écrire un nombre de textes qui vont
irriguer des générations militant extrê
il va repenser aussi l'organisation une
organisation quasiment militaire
militarisé de petits partis qui ont
vocation à prendre le pouvoir et aussi
c'est l'inventeur dominique Venner il
faut le souligner de l'art de la
dissimulation c'està-dire il explique à
toutes génération de militants attention
il faut faire attention au cho des mots
qu'on utilise il faut qu'on utilise un
lexique
inoffensif qui qui ne fasse pas peur
pour pouvoir séduire plus largement donc
il faut qu'on modère le ton les mots et
les méthodes sans changer de projet le
projet lui est toujours aussi radical en
quelque sorte c'est aussi le pionnier de
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la
dédiabolisation et évidemment on voit
qu'il a fait école jusqu'au
rassemblement national 1965 sa rencontre
avec Jean-Marie Le Pen va être
importante pendant la campagne
présidentielle de tix ven encour le
candidat de l'extrême droite c'est lui
qui va conseiller qui va conseiller
justement à Jean-Louis titic vin en
cours d'intégrer dans son programme
l'obsession migratoire le rejet de
l'immigration le rejet de l'altérité
comme étant la principale menace
souvenez-vous dans les années 50
l'extrême droite avait été incarné à un
moment par l'aventure dite de Pierre
Poujade les petits commerçants contre
l'État bureaucrate la fiscalité et
cetera la question migratoire n'était
pas dans cette ce logiciel là le
logiciel idéologique de l'extrême droite
il est changé métamorphosé par lappte de
vénère à partir de la campagne de 65
effectiv
cour puis Le Pen va nourir une
conception biologique et même
hiérarchique des races avec la la race
blanche tout en haut de la pyramide les
autres bien en dessousc vous racontez
beaucoup d'anecdotes vous racontez comme
si on y était parce que c'est très
documenté que dominique Venner va même
rencontrer François de Grossouvre le
conseiller de François mitteran dans les
années chasse tous les deux à la fois
ils étaient un peu obsédés par la
décadence et passionné de chasse celui
qui va permettre de faire les
intermédiaires avec Jean-Marie Le Pen
mais je voudrais qu'on s'arrête quand
même sur son suicide arme à feu
très préparé il ne renonce pas à sa
radicalité parce que ce geste il est
complètement politique il est en bonne
santé euh pourquoi décide-t-il de faire
ça comme ça il se suicide en 2013 à
Notre-Dame vous le disiez c'est un geste
totalement politique il s'agit pas d'un
geste il est en bonne santé il est pas
du tout c'est c'est un choix c'est un
appel à la révolte
àors au pied de l'hôtel de notreddame
attention c'est une extrême droite en
même temps il est un antichrétien il a
abandonné le christianisme qu'il
considère comme la la religion des
faibles parce que c'est la religion de
l'accueil de l'accueil de l'étranger du
pardon mais il s'expose à un malentendu
là et et il est c'est un c'est un un
tenant de l'extrême droite dite païenne
qui est totalement exalté par les mythes
greco-romains en quelque sorte d'où
d'ailleurs ce mythe du sacrifice il
choisit Notre-Dame parce que NotreDame
dans cette mythologie païenne a été bâti
sur un ancien temple à la gloire de
Jupiter un temple greco-romain au 1er
siècle après Jésus-Christ et il choisit
la dalle justement où selon cette
mythologie le temple a été bâti et c'est
donc un geste politique pour appeler le
peuple français il a laissé une
multitude d'écrits et de lettres aussi
qu'il a fait envoyer par ses amis dans
les heures qui ont suivi son suicide
pour appeler le peuple français à se
réveiller dit-il se réveiller contre la
menace de la disparition de l'Occident
et de la population européenne et il
faut souligner que ce suicide ce geste
éminemment politique hein qui se voulait
comme tel cet appel à la révolte a été
salué par Marine Le Pen ouais on va
revoir son tweet hein d'ailleurs on est
en 2013 d'ailleurs ça avait suscité un
peu la confusion parce qu'avec notre-
dame il y avait ce côté manif pour tous
et on a compris que ça n'avait rien à
voir après Marine Le Pen qui dit à sa
mort tout notre respect à dominique
Venner dont le dernier geste éminemment
politique aura été de tenter de
réveiller le peuple de France réveiller
le peuple de France c'est bien elle
reprend les termes de dominique Venner
et de tous ces écrits de tous ses
engagement qui donc ét parfois violent
parfois qui ont compris des des formes
différentes on le disait l'armée le
terrorisme le militantisme politique et
finalement le suicide tout ça c'est le
même engagement politique pour la même
obsession identitaire réveiller le
peuple français dit Marine Le Pen
contre l'obstion migratoire Marine Le
Pen si vous l'interroger sur Dominque
Venner elle va vous dire c'est la
préhistoire c'était il y a des décennies
c'est une traville histoire là on est en
2013 lorsqu'elle salue lorsqu'elle
applaudit ce ce suicide elle a failli
d'ailleurs aller à ses obsèes elle n'y
est pas allé par prudence électoraliste
bien sûr c'est un personnage trop
radical et trop sulfureux pour
s'afficher à ses obsèques elle y a
envoyé en revanche un de ses conseillers
de l'époque qui a fait passer d'ailleurs
un message de de soutien à la famille
mais elle reprend bien exactement les
mêmes obsessions 2013 c'est pas la
préhistoire était déjà présidente du
Front national à l'époque elle s'était
déjà présentée une fois en 2012 à sa
première campagne présidentielle et déjà
à l'époque et depuis d'ailleurs les
années 2004 2005 elle professait ce
qu'elle appelle la la dédiabolisation la
banalisation une extrêmedoite qui se
veut sympathique avenante et inoffensive
lorsqu'on regarde quel est le contenu
idéologique de ce projet on s'aperçoit
que si la forme a changé si l'apparence
peut sembler inoffensive le projet lui
reste tout a tout aussi radical et tout
aussi Obs
dernière question il y a toujours cette
tension euh et cette question comment
combattre le rassemblement national et
l'extrême droite en France est-ce qu'il
faut s'attaquer aux problèmes qui le
nourrissent l'immigration l'insécurité
ou au contraire rappeler ses origines et
l'argument moral vous vous situez où
dans ce débat alors très clairement dans
le la première alternative que vous
évoquez c'estàdire que l'extrême droite
ne progressent que quand les partis de
gouvernement échouent et sont incapables
de résoudre les problèmes qui se posent
au français donc c'est évidemment par
l'action politique que les partis
gouvern quel soit mais ce livre il est
pas moral il est là aussi pour dire aux
gens ce livre ce livre non mais pas
moral mais historique aucune
in voilà c'est une enquête que j'ai
évidemment nourri alimenté avec
d'innomrables lectures d'innomrables
documents et d'innombrables rencontres
évidemment de personnages de l'entourage
de dominique Venner sa sa veuve la
plupart de ses amis et cetera et j'ai
ausculté ça pendant pendant des mois et
des mois donc il y a absolument aucune
injonction morale dans mon livre en
revanche une enquête qui me semble assez
fouillée pour essayer de raconter
effectivement quel est le logiciel
idéologique et quelle est l'histoire de
dominique Venner et au-delà de tous ces
disciples qui font toujours aujourd'hui
de la politique une histoire qu'il faut
connaître donc merci beaucoup Renaud
d'IE ça se lit comme un roman même si
tout est vrai vous avez reconstitué
toutes les scènes et vous avez vu tous
ceux qui l'ont connu aujourd'hui et et
il se reconnaîtront certains sont même
encore les conseillers de Marine Le Pen
allez c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti prix vous
faites réagir on les accueille tout de
suite on termine comme chaque jeudi avec
yel Goose de France Inter et le grand
reporter Vincent UG pour l'international
bienvenue à tous les deux bonne année
puisque c'est votre première de 2024
installez-vous on commence par Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
c'est Elsa mondingava qui nous la
raconte bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je vais
vous parler d'une histoire de météo mais
je vous parle pas du froid qui fait
dehors je vous parle du froid qui existe
entre deux hommes politiques Emmanuel et
François Baou le patron du MoDem est
selon ses amis très énervé agacé
pourquoi et bien à cause du gouvernement
qu'il trouve trop à droite avec on le
rappelle le maintien de ministres issus
deslr Bruno le ma Gérald daranin
Sébastien le cor nu ou encore l'arrivée
de Catherine vautterin et de rachidati
alors le modem pas content on a posé la
question à haelquet c'est la
porte-parole du groupe ici à l'Assemblée
est-ce que là vous diriez que les
relations sont un peu compliquées en ce
moment un peu froid c'est un peu le
climat euh disons que il est vrai que
lorsqu'on regarde je le redis la
composition du gouvernement ça a pu nous
interroger il y a quand même beaucoup
plus de ministres issus de la droite que
de ministres issus de la gauche et ça
vous pose un
problème fondamentalement non ça ne pas
un problème tant qu'on n pas la la suite
de la du raniment en fait nous on attend
de voir les nominations et c'est vrai
que comme je l'ai déjà dit on attend un
rééquilibrage Auda
un rééquilibrage c'està-dire que le
modem et ben espère bien conserver ses
trois postes gouvernementaux quand on
aura si on a un jour la liste finale du
gouvernement même s'il reconnaissent que
de toute façon le mal est fait le mal
est fait donc alors pourquoi il il se
sent trahi François Baayou oui trahit
déjà de ne pas avoir été mis dans la
confidence de la nomination de Gabriel
hatal lui qui poussait un autre candidat
Julien de Normandie trahit aussi sur ces
arbitrages puisque non seulement
Catherine Vautrin et arachid hadti elles
sont de droite mais encore pire à ses
yeux elles sont de droite ite sarcoziste
et on sait que les deux hommes se
détestent et donc François baerou il a
le sentiment que son influence décroix
luck on le rappelle en 2017 c'était
sacrifié avait sacrifié sa propre
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
pour permettre l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron alors plus dur sera la revanche
du maire de poau ou pas alors chez
Renaissance en tout cas on ne panique
pas on pense que les choses finiront
bien par se tasser que ça frotte un peu
dans ces moments très politiques c'est
normal mais avec François Baayou et le
modem ça s'apèera très vite après ouis
moi je je je vois surtout que depuis
2017 François baayrou et le modem sont
des alliés solides au sein de la
majorité mais qui savent faire
l'entendre leur voix et c'est bien
normal et donc oui nous sommes dans un
moment particulier de recomposition de
de remanement ministériel ils défendent
leur intérêt moi je je serai à leur
place je ferai comme eux côté modem on a
bien agité la menace d'une liste
indépendante pour les européennes même
si ça a un peu fait pit on parle d'une
prise de parole du président du MoDem
bientôt mais on reconnaît qu'il est un
peu coincé en tout cas jusqu'au 5
février c'est la date du délibéré dans
le procès des assistants parlementaires
du MoDem merci beaucoup Elsa il a perdu
du poids politique c'est net Franou
doute en plus il pensait et ça a été le
cas de nombreuses reprises être un peu
l'homme qui soufflait à l'oride d'
Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 donc toutes
ces raisons effectivement avancé sont
sont vraies bien sûr gouvernement trop à
droite entre autres à ses yeux mais je
pense qu'il y a aussi un autre problème
c'est un premier ministre trop jeune à
ses yeux c'est humain Gabriel à 34 ans
François baron en a 72 donc c'est sûr
que c'est une nomination qu'il n'a pas
accueilli avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme
allez il AEL Goose la politique on vient
de vivre une des semaines les plus
politiques de skinena conférence de
presse du Président de la République
mardi soir Emmanuel Macron c'est-il
selon vous réarmé dans la durée c'est
intéressant ce ce mot durée que vous
utilisez parce que sous la 5e République
quand tout va mal c'est le temps la
gestion du temps qui est la dernière
ressource que vous avez encore à votre
disposition dans lequelle puisez pour
espérer rebondir quand on est un chef de
l'État malmené de ce point de vue bah la
réponse et oui Emmanuel Macron a repris
le contrôle de l'horloge il faut voir
d'où l'on vient il y a un mois il était
obligé de convoquer sa majorité à
l'Élysée en catastrophe pour la forcer à
voter une loi immigration rédigé par la
droite inspiré par l'extrême droite
Emmanuel Macron l'homme du barrage en
2017 puis en 2022 obligé même s'il s'en
défend de concéder une victoire
symbolique à Marine Le Pen alors ce sont
pas les vœux du 31 décembre qui ont
changé la DAT mais tout ce qui a suivi
première quinzaine de janvier
remanimement intern àalisé changement de
communicant chamboulement à Matignon
Gabriel tal évidemment la surprise
nomination d'un gouvernement en poids
lourd et l'ouverture jusqu'à Rachida
Dati donc vous nous dites que la
politique c'est du casting dans la
maîtrise de l'horloge myiam le
remanimement c'est c'est l'une des
aiguilles c'est la trotteuse et Emmanuel
Macron il veut la faire tourner tout au
long du mois de janvier voir un peu plus
l'équipe finale ne sera sans doute pas
connue avant le discours de politique
général de Gabriel àal ça ça serait
inédit et ça fige les oppositions dans
l'attente et dans la réaction et puis il
y a l'aiguille du temps long c'est la
conférence de presse golienne d'Emmanuel
Macron mardi soir là encore pour effet
de avec pour effet de saturer l'espace
des chantiers sont ouverts tous asimud
parfois un peu vague hein natalité
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire exactement
contrôle des écrans pour la mineur mais
c'est pas grave pour les mineurs c'est
pas grave c'est on en parle ça fait des
vagues et c'est ce qui compte ça fait du
mouvement c'est quand il y a plus de
mouvement à macrony que elle droite et
gauche se regarde en chien de faillance
quand ça bouge et non plus le temps donc
c'est gagné pour vous il a repris le
contrôle de son mandat je dirais pas
qu'il est réarmé je dirait qu'il a
retrouvé de l'oxygène mais seulement ça
parce que
l'hypercommunication n'empêchera jamais
les quakes les erreurs grossière
polémique ou da Castera et puis
nomination prématurée nomination
candidature pardon prématurée de Rachid
adti pour Paris le bougisme emprunté à
Nicolas Sarkozi n'empêchera pas la
semaine prochaine le Conseil
constitutionnel de censurer une bonne
partie de la loi immigration l'hypercom
ne peut rien non plus contre une courbe
du chômage et des tarifs EDF à la hausse
Emmanuel Macron le sait il fait de la
politique même blessé il fait du judo au
moins jusqu'au Jo problème si les
européennes se passent mal est-ce que ce
dispositif son nouveau dispositif aura
encore du sens s'il est largement
devancé par le RN l'horloger ne sera
plus très point de la retraite h merci
beaucoup yel go je laisse du temps pour
réagir à la chronique sur l'équateur
parce que c'est important ce qui s'y
passe Vincent eugu vous allez nous
parler de de ce pays en proie au gang et
au narcotrafic un procureur a été
assassiné et oui nager considéré comme
un havre de paix l'équateur désormais
livré à la loi des cartels et des gangs
n'en finit plus de sombrer sans doute
vous souvenez-vous de l'épisode du
buesque qui le 9 janvier avait propulsé
sous les feux de rampes médiatiques ce
petit pays latino-américain au 18
millions d'âmes ce jour-là un commandoau
d'une douzaine de portefingues encagoulé
surgit sur le plateau d'une chaîne de
télévision de la cité portuaire de
Guayakil ces membres plaquent au sol
puis tiennent en joue des techniciens et
journalistes terrorisés sans se priver
de fanfaronné devant les caméras bien
sûr la police mettra fin promptement à
ce direct glaçant mais certes pas à ce
mauvais feuilleton d'abord parce que
l'assau n'est que le point d'org d'un
déferlement de violence déclenché par
l'évasion d'un cahide redouté surnommé
phito avec dans les prisons prise
d'otage de gardien mais aussi équipé
sauvage dans les rues de Guayakil et de
la capitale Quito ensuite et surtout
parce que le procureur chargé de
l'enquête Carlos Suarez a été assassiné
hier au volant de sa voiture on en
oublierait presque que le flan ouest de
l'écador est baigné par l'océan
Pacifique donc le pays a perdu le
contrôle de son destin et oui pour son
malheur et bien il a accédé au statut
peu enviable de tête de pont des réseaux
d'exportation de la cocaïne produite par
ses voisins Pérou et et Colombie 70 % de
la coque qui arrive en Europe provient
d'Équateur et les 4/5e de ce funeste
flux partent du port de Guayakil
précisément comment très simple à bord
de pyrog les narcos approchent les
tankers en partance se isent à bord à
l'aide d'échelles et de grappins font
sauter les scellés des conteneurs pour y
glisser leur poudre mortelle reste à
leurs associés des cartels mexicains et
de la mafia albanaise à orchestré la
réception sous ne latitude qu' lue cru
le narcotrafic et la corruption on peut
à peu gangrainer l'appareil d'État à
commencé par la police la magistrature
l'administration pénitentiaire ceux qui
ont l'audace de le combattre de dénoncer
un tel cancer le P souvent de leur vie
et les politiques n'échappent pas
évidemment au carnage à preuve
l'assassinat en août dernier d'un
candidat à la présidence Fernando villa
vicencio ou celui du maire de la ville
de Manta alors comment les autorités
réagissent est-ce qu'elles arrivent à à
enrayer cette cette dérive un peu plus
d'un an du prochain scrutin présidentiel
le trentenaire Daniel Noboa a choisi la
guerre totale
entre couvre-feu et déploiement de 20000
militaires pas sûr que cette option
dictée par l'urgence suffira à
neutraliser les 22 gangs recensés sur le
territoire les précédents du Salvador du
Mexique de la Colombie invitent à la
circonspection tous les experts
s'accordent sur ce constat la manière
forte peut s'avérer efficace à court
terme jamais dans la durée à quoi bon
par exemple raflés trafiquants et tueurs
pour les entasser dans des prisons que
contrôlent de fait les cador de la cam
embastiller les chefs fort bien à ceci
près que leur mise à l'ombre d'ailleurs
toute relative favorisent l'émergence
d'héritiers plus jeunes plus
imprévisiblebl plus impitoyable point de
remède miracle donc voilà pourquoi
Mexico et Bokota ont amorcé une
inflexion stratégique priorité affichée
en tout cas au programmes sociaux et à
la lutte contre la pauvreté ceux qui
prétendent qu'ils ont mieux en magasin
que cet effort de longue haleine à
l'issue incertaine fourgue des chimères
et se shoot au mensonge merci beaucoup
Vincent e je on en parle peu on se
croirait dans une série Netflix dans
narcos et c'est la réalitéand on observe
effectivement les fondements de
l'équateur depuis depuis quelques
semaines on mesure à quel point un
certain nombre de de
gang sont devenus des des des quasiment
des des mafias quasiment des
multinationales qui qui se font la
guerre en plus parce que si l'équateur
exporte de plus en plus enfin ces gangs
de de de de cocaïne vers l'Europe c'est
aussi parce qu'il y a moins de débouché
en Amérique du Nord parce qu'il y a la
concurrence d'une autre drogue qui
faitavage en Amérique du Nord c'est le
fintanil cette fameuse drogue dit du
zombie drog de synthèse où là on a des
d'autres mafias qui sont notamment qui
viennent notamment d'Asie et notamment
de Chine aussi qui fournissent les
produits pour pour produire cette drogue
qui produit des effets terribles aux
États-Unis qui plus que le covid aux
États-Unis les les ports des Pays-Bas
sont perméables à ces gangs désormais au
Pays-Bas chez nous he on mesure cette
rivalité entre ces différents ce
intéressant c'est que dans la relation
tempétueuse entre Pékin et Washington on
parle beaucoup et à bon droit de Taïwan
mais ceci est l'un des dossiers majeurs
et lors des derniers contacts directs
entre le chinois si Jinping et Joe Biden
il a été question du fantanil et de ses
ravages absolument dévastateur dans
toutes les grandes villes des États-Unis
merci beaucoup on s'arrête là merci les
affranchis merci Elsa à très vite et
Merci à VOUS mer beaucoup Renaud dé il
faut lire l'assiégé dans la tête de
dominique Venner le gourou caché de
l'extrême droite chez lat Dominique
vennerre sans mauvais jeu de mot
toujours assez vénéré par certains à
l'extrême droite très belle soirée
documentaire sur LCP avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien à
[Musique]
demain